ladies and gentlemen here's the story
from today from CBS News atlanta-based
Morris Brown College says they are
reinstating covid mask mandates
Lionsgate reinstates mask made it in
parts of Santa Monica office following
covet outbreak and don't forget the New
York Post amid summer surge of new cove
Advantage should we be wearing masks no
you've also no you've also got a bunch
of stories about uh Biden advocating for
people to start getting their vaccines
once again we've got a new vaccine
variant being released this fall
according to Forbes but it seems very
likely at least right now that covid
mandates will be returning now the story
started with none other than Alex Jones
who said that he spoke with the TSA
whistleblower who said that they had
been called into a meeting to discuss
the new coveted policies in by October
they will be in full-blown covid policy
mandate Etc
I don't know that's guaranteed because
often when there's a big backlash when
we talk about things when other shows
talk about it then these stories might
disappear because they're worried about
a big splash shocking people so maybe
maybe nothing happens
but I do got to say I don't know what
else the Democrats can do to try to win
in 2024 because they desperately need
that procedural help when it comes to
Universal mail and voting
they could Supply a good candidate that
would help Robert F Kennedy I don't know
if he really has a chance in hell the
problem with the Democratic party is
they have super delegates so they can
just pick the candidate so it doesn't
really matter who votes Yahoo and just
to decide that that's that's we're going
to run this time so nice Democratic
Republic well it's like you know the
Democrats of the Harlem Globetrotters
and the Republicans of the Washington
generals it's pretty accurate I think so
yeah
uh Michelle Obama doesn't want to run I
hear well why do you keep bringing
Michelle Obama I've heard that she wants
or they wanted to run they Wicked wanted
to run because she would win but but she
doesn't want to do it I would have I
would have agreed that a couple years
ago I'm not so convinced today Trump got
75 million votes in 2020 that is more
than he he got more like more votes than
any sitting uh president any incumbent
and historically I believe this is true
a president who received more votes in
their re-election has never lost until
Trump there were a lot of things that
affected 2020 but the most important
factor here a Democratic party well for
sure I mean judges Governors policy
changes lawsuits Etc but when all of
these never trumpers and Democrats are
saying Trump can't win actually now the
Democrats are saying Trump can win and
probably will win and you get these
never trumpers being like no no Trump
can't win even when Democrats are like
actually it's looking pretty good for
Trump
Donald Trump lost by only about 42 000
votes in three states yeah he can easily
remedy that and especially with Joe
Biden's failures my concern with these
covet these coveted lockdowns not so
much my concern but my thinking on this
I'm not so convinced it'll get as bad as
many people think because
Joe Biden's president
the Democrats have the Senate if they
start locking things down and forcing
mandates on people it's Joe Biden's
fault maybe that's opening the door to
bring in a Gavin Newsom or something
because they can't run Biden but this
will not help Joe Biden I think the
easiest way to kind of view all the
actions that Democrats do is through the
Paradigm of obviously accusing your
enemies of what you're guilty of and I
think for so long they accused Donald
Trump of you know conspiring to overturn
the election results and sort of more
broadly the Republican party that's what
they did in 2020 and even from the the
onset of Trump's campaign in 2016 right
it was Russia foreign collusion and I
really think that if you look at the
pandemic through that lens in other
words they use the mail-in voting they
used the pandemic as an excuse to allow
a bunch of money from you know these
Mark Zuckerberg line groups to really
change the way that elections were run
to really turn it into nothing that
resembles a free and fair election and I
think that is why they have been going
so hard accusing Donald Trump in the
Trump campaign of trying to alter
election results in conspiracy overseas
to you know overturn elections because
in reality that's what they're
fundamentally trying to do and I think
one of the ways they do it is the Loft
bear with the indictments and stuff like
that but I think these kova 19 mandates
it's another form of lawfare that is
almost more nefarious I think that the
the we were talking earlier um about the
the point just being to get mail-in
ballots out I think that the lockdowns
are just going to be
I think that the government and stuff
will say okay you should lock down or
there will be lockdowns I think there's
going to be a large vast majority of
Americans are going to ignore it and
then the government's just going to
behave as if
everyone's doing what they say they're
going to do they're gonna act like
everyone's listening like everyone's
locking down and everyone's gonna be
like it's so weird that they keep saying
that this is at like we should lock down
but nobody does anything and they're
going to use it as an excuse so that way
they can mail out ballots again so that
way they get the balance into people's
hands I think 98 I agree with you I
would tweak it only slightly
I think what they may end up doing is
they'll say we realize that you know
hard lockdown policies were were widely
condemned and so listening to the will
of the people we are going to roll out
our guidelines that you lock down but no
no this time No One's Gonna Force you
and then because that was under Trump
that you were forced Joe Biden and they
can still use it as an excuse to send
out the ballots absolutely and they'll
say and because our guidelines are as
such we'll be sending out mail-in
ballots to every single home in the
state well and remember too that I think
it was either this week or next week
there was a lot of consternation over
the fact that Joe Biden was potentially
going to declare a climate emergency and
use it as a pretext to kind of Institute
climate lockdowns and whatnot so frankly
I always thought that it would be more
likely that they would bring about the
second round of lockdowns via the like
climate change or other kind of
manufacturing I don't know how that
works because the the first lockdowns
people would like myself included gave
the government the best gave him the
benefit of the doubt said okay we're
gonna say if you if the stuff that
you're saying is true it could be a
problem so we're going to give you the
benefit of that
how on Earth
are they going to convince people that
are adults that are that are 35 and
older that have been seeing climate
alarmism for their entire life how are
they going to get those people to
actually believe that this new issue
that they're bringing up is actually
worth locking down for and you have to
stop how do you how do they do it easy
how smog
When the Smoke came here I was messed up
I woke up my throat was on fire and I
was I was short of breath are we seeding
the clouds together are we starting
fires to get smoke I mean I'm just
saying they're going to use the smoke
problem as a pretext for we need to do
something about this now I'm not saying
they're starting fires I'm saying
they've already said the smoke is going
to come back this fall surprise surprise
yeah because of their because there are
particular policies that like allowed
for these rainforests to like not
reinforest but Forest to build up alone
Modesta literally said the Maui fires
are because of climate change so they
obviously are using all these crises
it's going to have to get widespread but
not so Extreme as Maui but when you have
that's that smoke was brutal it was
really really bad and uh wait we had to
bring the chickens inside because the
chickens are low to the ground where did
you put this we put them in a shed we
put him in a shed we had we had to get
some kind of like air conditioning
because it was too hot but the uh you
need something to put them inside to
deal with the particulates because they
can die
you get enough of those events where
people keep panicking and people are
getting sick and people going to the
hospital and then they're gonna say we
have to do something about climate
change and I mean even look at Hurricane
Hillary in California I'm from
California my parents are there they
sent me videos and I sort of joked them
I was like it just looks like it's
raining and not I'm sure people were
injured hurricanes look like you know no
one no one died in California right I
think I'm correct and that one person
maybe died in Mexico but my parents said
you went to the grocery stores every
single thing except for sliced white
bread was gone and I think that shows
you how the media if they really can
manufacture a narrative around some you
know looming and pending natural
disaster whether it's the smog a
hurricane this that even if in reality
it's not actually as intense as they
want it to be they can sort of like a
social engineer a reaction or a response
to it that elicits almost in some ways a
reaction that's worse than her I agree
but I got to respond to this
crazy right hurricanes are just drizzle
at Hurricane Sandy in New York there was
no rain at all and this is a mistake I
made when I was in Hurricane Irene in
Virginia uh that uh don't get me wrong
hurricanes can't have rain and yeah
there was some rain for Sandy so when I
was in San Diego tonight I'm standing
near the stock exchange in the financial
district watching Manhattan flood and
the waters are rising and we're putting
sandbags out and all there was no strong
wind and there was no rain at this time
and all you heard was a because the wind
was going above the buildings and being
uh refracted from the buildings when I
was in Irene no strong rain at all and I
was shocked and I was like where's the
rain so I see all these videos from
people and they're like this is the
great hurricane it's just drizzle and
then you have this massive flooding
sweeping through the LA River and man
there's this video of these guys jogging
and they it the the water is Raging next
to them as they're on this this walking
path and then they come to this uh this
water that's flowing rapidly across the
path and they up and Skip through it and
I'm like that's how you die because you
put one foot down it pushes you over and
you get swept into that massive raging
Storm current and then you're dead the
issue with hurricanes is always storm
surge and I also want to add we know
that the hurricane in Los Angeles wasn't
climate change it was the wrath of God
over the Dragons I'm kidding but it is
it is crazy to see we've got uh the news
is the most important factor in whether
or not you get a reaction
if the media and and even we are guilty
of this and everyone's guilty of this
the media dictates The Narrative and the
story they all their journalists will
just start talking about the same thing
and then all the conservatives will come
out and react to it so when they decide
the big story is going to be these fires
everyone's like oh the fires all the
fires and then you're going to get more
and more news where they're going to put
the smog death counter and they're gonna
yup and then people and they're gonna be
like we have to do something about it
and then all of the Democrats and all
the neolibs are going to be like why
aren't you locking down it's the it's
the smog it's coming it's climate change
I believe it's entirely possible I
imagine there will be a lot more uh
interpersonal conflict with people on
the street with people saying why you
know when it comes to people that are
complaining about oh why aren't you
locking down and then the the people
that don't want to lock down don't want
to wear a mask they're not going to be
quiet about it anymore like again people
gave the benefit of the doubt the first
time in 2020. they're not going to give
the benefit of the doubt anymore yeah 15
days to school
as soon as someone says something about
oh why aren't you wearing your mask
someone's gonna be like because I want
to get you know whatever they're gonna
just you know give a bunch of lip and
it's going to be a lot of Confrontation
I've got a feeling the people not all of
them but for the most part if people are
scared into wearing masks by TV shows
those are cap those are cowardly people
that's that's a behavior of cowards and
cowards aren't very likely to come out
on the street and challenge you for not
wearing a mask they absolutely if
they're if they're afraid then they're
going to be like that person is
endangering me and it's going to be a
fear response when they go up to them
and confront them it's not going to be
about asserting themselves for dominance
it's going to be you're going to hurt me
that's that's and that's always what the
what the case was when it came to the
people that were like oh you know you're
not wearing your mask it's always like
you should be wearing your mask because
you're gonna hurt me
I uh I'm I liken back to 2020 and I
think you just said it 15 days to slow
spread the only reason in hell I would
ever lock my country down is because
there was some sort of flesh-eating
virus tearing through the population you
never do that to your country unless it
was the last ditch effort circumstance
that you have no other choice you lost
running water you lost soap if in those
situations maybe because you that that
is the recipe to destroy your country is
to shut it down don't do that again and
don't make people put dirty
masks on
nice I'm sick of it man I'm sick
of it I will not do it again
thank you
I wonder how many people feel exactly
the same way yeah I agree well you know
we're out in West Virginia so we came
out here because we were in New Jersey
and it started getting really intense
there was talk locally about shutting
down the bridges out of New Jersey and I
was like I'm leaving I'm not gonna stick
around to wait and find out if I'm
trapped on this peninsula so we uh we
were working on setting up the new
studio and we were like let's just go
down early and we'll figure it out and
we'll we'll make it work the problem was
the internet wasn't set up and so we had
to use this like janky internet but I
was like don't know don't care don't
want to be in New Jersey anymore so we
came out here and then surprise surprise
you know the interesting thing about
coming out to West Virginia we're in the
tri-state which is Maryland Virginia
West Virginia
the further you go towards the cities
the more you have to wear masks you go
into Maryland they're nuts you cross
into West Virginia ain't nobody wearing
masks I mean there are some people will
you might see some people somewhere but
for the most part nobody was so I'm just
saying you know when I say get out of
cities it's not just about whether or
not you'll be safe it's about whether
you be comfortable
but if you want to live in those
lockdowns I I I I look
if the government announces climate
change lockdowns you know all these
Democrats are going to be the
krakensteins are going to make the the
the the rational argument on Twitter to
engage in conversation about why the
climate change lockdowns are absolutely
required and why Joe Biden is right to
Institute them they will fall in line in
two seconds did they mention climate
change lockdowns or is this just an idea
they're talking about it because if you
remember no no not the krakensteins I'm
saying they're an example of they often
come out with the establishment
narrative and try to make a reasonable
conversation about why it's correct they
don't they don't come out like most Libs
screaming and like
you know they're just like I'd like to
have a discussion about it it's I mean I
respect it but I'm just saying they will
be doing it I am more likely to
decide that a new pandemic is more
dangerous and I would lock down for a
new pandemic than I am for a climate
change Locker oh yeah like it would take
actual like I would have to be it would
be forced they'd have to be like you you
have to leave you can't come in they'd
have to kick me out of everywhere I'm
not staying in my house you know I I
think the uh the initial lockdowns the
reason why we all gave the benefit of
the doubt to the government was because
they were talking about this novel
respiratory virus with a high mortality
rate yeah and so we're all like we got
to figure out what's going on
now that hindsight is 2020 we all look
back like oh what a waste of time that
was so dumb but yeah we were seeing
these these videos of people and China
collapsing in the street and people are
getting scar tissue in their lungs I
think the alpha strain of covid was
really really really bad and then what
happens is this at least this is how the
corporate press has described it over
time the more serious strains
cease because they cause too much damage
to the host and limit its ability to
spread somebody who's so sick their
incapacitated can't spread the virus so
the weaker versions that start emerging
keep people somewhat active feeling a
little under the weather and that more
easily spread so over time the variants
will become weaker but more contagious
or I guess that's how they described it
uh yeah so at the time when they were
saying look at what we're saying we were
seeing very very serious stuff I can I
can respect that nobody knew and I can
say now we know and now we should be uh
more careful about how we enact these
things things that being said we've
talked about it on this show you brought
it up Ian what if it was an Airborne
Ebola that's what I'm talking about and
then we're like okay that's actually a
really good question I still think you
have the responsibility to quarantine if
you want to and I put my faith and trust
in our government and our world's
governments during covid because I
thought maybe it was going to be a
flesh-eating bacteria and I was like I'm
not gonna play God on this one but after
the 15 days ended and they kept going
for month like another 15 days and
another 15 days it was like and then I
found out about the bio labs in in Wuhan
that Anthony fauci's involved in I'm
like okay so they what they built this
thing and then it got loose is that the
story now this is disgusting I'm not
saying there can't be another bio weapon
let loose on people but like it's not
worth destroying the global economy
because of it you've got to take care of
yourself thank you Tim that's a good
point you have to take care of yourself
first you need a healthy body you need
to eat healthy you need to get enough
sunlight and enough sleep you need to
get soap and drink enough water and if
if you're hearing in the news that
they're saying there's an Airborne Ebola
with a 50 mortality rate
it should still be your choice whether
or not you want to go out and go to work
the government forcing you to stay home
is stupid they're like no you can't
leave now if there's an Airborne but
again we're talking about something
that's very extreme but there's an
Airborne Ebola people you're gonna see
people you're going to see people
literally bleeding out of their eyes and
you're gonna it's gonna be real easy to
make the decision ain't nobody gonna be
like lemon think about it do I need to
go get them smokes not no everyone's
staying home you know actually but you
see these open-air drug markets
these videos out of Philadelphia in Los
Angeles oh yeah skid row and stuff dude
I imagine if if there's a pandemic like
a more serious one that gets to that
level of like 10 20 30 there's going to
be videos of all of these people being
like like zombie was nasty when they
couldn't before they knew leprosy was
like just a bacteria that eats flesh
before they had soap really they
couldn't wash it off that's basically
the Cure I they they would touch
people's bodies and they would get the
bacteria on their own skin and then
their skin would start to get eaten and
they thought it was contagious like so
they would quarantine lepers but like
leprosy is not that easy just reading
about it last night oh cool I gotta read
a Super Chat normally we wait until the
end of super chats but it's too good
chaser says Ian just broke the die to
reveal a 21 inside yes
yes I love that I love I love how the
saying hindsight is 20 20 like literally
applies to covid because it literally
was the year 2020. I know isn't that
weird I actually I can't take credit for
that I had a hair stylist who was like
super hippy dippy and into all this
stuff and she was giving me all these
sayings oh my gosh but I think what
enrages me the most and I obviously did
a lot of reporting on Anthony fauci and
the bio labs and the Wuhan Institute of
virology is that this very same group
Eco Health Alliance was sort of
funneling the taxpayer funds to the
Wuhan Institute of virology they have
continued to receive multi-million
dollar grants from the federal
government even from the Department of
Defense particularly working on believe
it or not the grants are under the
weapons of mass destruction category
sort of in the bio weapon territory and
they've renewed even that really
controversial Grant um from Nya the
National Institute of allergy and
infectious diseases to Eco Health the
same Grant they were working with the
Chinese Communist Party run lab on these
you know manipulating back coronaviruses
and also it's so enraging because you
hear all these Western scientists still
sort of championing uh the crusade of
you know oh we need to partner with
Scientists in China who are all under
the thumb of the Chinese Communist party
and it just seems like the establishment
has not learned their lesson at all when
it comes to pandemic prevention and I
think it goes back to what we were all
saying and really what I think is is at
the core of our frustration with these
lockdowns and these mandates is that
these alleged people who are supposed to
be stopping these pandemics who are in
the business of pandemic prevention also
concurrently seem to be the very same
people who are benefiting when the
pandemics hit because when they
Institute the lockdowns the mandates it
just increases their power right it just
increases their ability to basically
control society and I think for me
looking at it through again my very
Niche lens of like the Wuhan Institute
of virology and who's funding all these
entities they haven't learned their
lessons so when you see the same voices
on the mainstream media telling us we
need to lock down and always ending
their segments with the you know wagging
their fingers saying you need to wear a
mask it's like you know shut up you guys
haven't learned your lesson I usually
don't get fired up but it's just these
people are so full of it and if they
think they can do it again YouTube has
their New World Health Organization
policy I guess they got rid of the covid
policy and now they're doing the
straight up World Health Organization
policy where you can't defy them or
whatever but they should well this will
be interesting to see YouTube said
YouTube launched their World Health
Organization saying the quiet part out
loud yeah yeah they're saying it used to
be the covid policy and now it's just
the who policy or whatever so we'll see
what new rules they start rolling out
randomly that seem to make no sense and
the pandemic treaty too I feel like
we're talking about all this with the
variable being the Biden regime right
but I think the climate lockdowns are
something that would probably be
instituted I would argue more from a
Global Perspective I think they would
probably emanate more so out of the
United Nations and if you really look at
the Genesis the origins of the concept
of climate lockdowns and combating
climate change through mandates and
stuff like that it really it's not
really a Biden regime idea it's more of
a United Nations idea I want to say one
thing before we go to the next story I'm
just imagining that there are some like
deep State intelligence agency guys who
have to watch the show every night and
they just saw Ian snap and now they're
all scared like have we gone too far
dude yes you have gone too far it's not
you personally things have gone too far
it's time to reel it in a lot of people
feel like I feel right now you like the
barometer for like weird middle of the
road dude in this country who typically
doesn't pay attention and now he's
getting angry and they're like I think
we've pushed people too far thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time